anthony truchi a prêté serment il y a
quatre ans dominique clément elle est
avocate depuis 1992 et ils ont chacun
leur vision de la sphère grigori je
dirais battage médiatique et naufrage
judiciaire de deux mots pour moi c'est
surréaliste et tragique
la mise en examen de christine villemin
le non-lieu retentissant de la chambre
de l'instruction de dijon
le procès de jean marie villemin autant
d'épisodes anciens de la ferc a suivi m
clément à l'époque c'est une affaire
hors norme elle intéresse tout le monde
dans ce pays c'est ça d'ailleurs le
drame peut-être de cette affaire parce
qu'elle touche à la mort d'un enfant
elle touche à des secrets de famille a
des choses de 13 ans tine de l'andrh de
la haine fratricide afin de nous quelque
chose de très sombres de l'âme humaine
et c'est en ça qu'elle qu'elle passionne
tout le monde évidemment la jeune
avocate que j'étais ne pouvait être que
passionné par tout ce qui se déroulait
la cour d'appel de dijon
à cette époque l'âme c'est un dossier
qui a marqué génération de mes parents
et la génération mes grands parents ma
génération - mais après c'est subjectif
c'est à dire que c'est mon avis nous
avons été moins marquée par ce dossier
un dossier revenu dans l'actualité il ya
tout juste un an et dont les derniers
épisodes vont interpeller les deux
avocats s'étaient surtout l'aspect
procédure parce que ce dossier du coup
est très ancien donc ils posent de
vraies questions de procédure est
d'ailleurs un arrêt récent la chambre
d'instruction de dijon sur ce thème je
porte un regard de juristes sur la sur
l'aspect procédure pénale dans ce
dossier mais également de même à
regarder citoyen sur ce dossier on peut
qu'emporter 1 notamment à travers le
drame qu'a constitué la mort de bernard
laroche par exemple après l'annulation
des dernières mises en examen les deux
avocats s'interrogent aussi sur l'avenir
de cette affaire hors norme c'est pas la
fin du dossier je pense pas est-ce que
la preuve pour être apporté de façon
judiciaire je ne sais pas anthony truffy
comme dominique clément espère que la
vérité finira par éclater mais
s'accordent pour parler de dossiers est
maudit